This better be the right place
It is
cause if this isn't the right place, someone's about to be real confused
Barry!
hey!
I knew it! I knew that was you. I knew it was you in that weird space portal. yeah yeah
it took us a couple tries to get here. this is my friend Cisco
well, friend is a loose term, we work together
I have to say, this is a nice universe you have here
do you remember last year when I helped you out and you promised to do the same for me?
What are we up against?
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so were finally
here crossover time has started this can be
an explanation for what's going on what you
need to do it is a shout out I'm bringing
the flash ring giveaway bags all explained
that the second but watches quick behind-the-scenes
that I'll explain everything so three-way
invasion.
So I hope Telesis it starts out like a normal
episode and then suddenly yes that is a meteor
and yes it is heading for downtown but is
very runs to see how we can stop anybody getting
hurt but he realizes that this really is merit
meteor at all.
It's an alien ship and the aliens are he sees
for the first time that aliens do exist and
there the creepiest thing to ever seen them
and they go by the name dominators is not
the name of the species that comes in case
you know it very aggressive Barry thinks the
best idea is to create the superhero team
you must all the super from the cell can get
together and go fight to aliens you locked
your mind on top about if the gonna fight
aliens he wants to use mailing the train against
them.
So he goes to earth 38 and gets Kara Zor El
known as supergirl last year when helped out
and you comes to the same for me.
This Is going to be great and the Flash rings
are back in stock just to explain the giveaway
it's just like normal.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video but make
sure that you turn alerts on click that little
bell, so that you get all the videos just
because YouTube is being weird and people
been missing out on stuff.
nowwhat the hell's going on with this giant
crossover, so last night.
On Supergirl, it was largely a self-contained
episode just for Supergirl stuff that was
happening not crossover stuff but every once
in a while during like really weird moments
portals would open like Cisco was trying to
find his way to her earth.
They still haven't technically given her earth,
the designation like they jokingly call it,
earth CBS.
So like Cisco's been trying to find it every
once in a while but something really crazy
happens the portal opens like she's getting
her ass handed to her by cyborg Superman he
says no one will be able to help you.
All the sudden the portal opens like anything
that Barry is going to jump through and kick
his ass but he doesn't.
So they get to the end of the episode which
is kind of like an eradicate or type story.
I'll explain that in the second.
But then Barry and Cisco are finally able
to open a portal inside her apartment.
So even I was a little surprised with how
like the crossover was but they said the reason
they did it this way is because Supergirl's
earth is still in a different universe.
They haven't got to the point where they want
to combine it with berries like the neck in
a do like some giant universe changing thing
yet.
Maybe for next year's crossover.
Now that they've introduced the idea of aliens
and Earth one which is where flash and arrow's
are this.
So tonight on the flash episode eight is the
first real night of the big crossover like
it's all dominators storyline from here on
out.
So tonight on the flash episode eight then
tomorrow on arrow on their hundredth episode,
then on legends of tomorrow legends is the
last night of the crossover if for some reason
you haven't been watching all the shows it's
totally okay like the stories are very self-contained
to this big crossover so you have no idea
what's up with Prometheus on arrow or you
don't know the ledge the be doing this season
you'll be totally fine just watch the episodes
I'll be doing like full episode videos for
the flash arrow in legends of tomorrow with
a couple bonus videos in between the be couple
extra crossover videos this week, just because
what they're doing is so big, which makes
the video schedule just a little bit weird
but all explained that at the end of the video
but what's happening is the dominators are
invading Earth one Justin Barry and Oliver's
universe Supergirl is in a different universe
but they did say after this big crossover
event the dominators would come back in the
future.
On Supergirl.
So I'm guessing that's dominators from a different
universe.
So last night.
On Supergirl, it was largely a self-contained
episode just for Supergirl stuff that was
happening not crossover stuff.
That's probably because just Supergirl Mon-El
the characters themselves like Martian Manhunter
are galactic characters so it's easier for
them to do galactic villains.
But on the flash and arrow, most of the villains
come from earth.
So even though they're going to defeat the
dominators.
Somehow there still going to continue to be
a big character just like the flash defeats
the rogues, they always come back just like
Oliver was able to fight off deathstroke he
always comes back speaking of which Arrow
100th episode.
Their lot of you that haven't been watching
arrow for the last season or two their hundredth
episode is going to be crazy make sure you
watch that if you have not been watching arrow
as we go along.
I'll be doing Easter egg videos for the flash
later tonight than arrow legends of tomorrow
bonus videos throughout just for special things
that like way above and beyond but next week
what's can happen is is a all get their midseason
finale the go back to their own storylines
to like the flash will go back to fighting
Dr. alchemy and's savitar arrow will go back
to fighting Prometheus the ranks can be doing
some pretty crazy stuff on arrow in the midseason
finale episode 10 when they come back in January,
most of you have probably been watching the
flash you might not have been watching arrow
so there supposed to be some huge twist with
black canary coming back on arrow in the back
half of the season so make sure you watch.
I mean obviously I'll be doing videos for
but make sure you watch to see how they pull
it off because they've already said that they're
not to be using a lot of the twists that they
used in the past for bringing back dead characters.
So like the Arrow 100th episode, Katie Cassidy
is going to be in that.
The twist is a little bit different it's going
to be like that Batman the animated series
episode perchance to dream, so is gonna feel
very different because it's gonna be a dreamlike
state so supposedly that's not how they're
bringing back Laurel even though she will
be back for that episode and I do expect Tommy
to be in that to they pretty much brought
every big character that's ever been on Arrow
so that means that deathstroke is gonna be
kicking a lot of ass, so the still be a bunch
of dominators stuff happening the be a lot
of special Arrow 100th episode stuff happening.
So don't worry if you guys have big questions
about what's going on how it's gonna work.
Just let me know in the comments of it on
in my flash video after the episode airs tonight
it's gonna be so crazy.
I can't even believe that they attempted to
crossover for shows it is some Rick and Morty
level should that's going on here.
And yes I will be doing a.
Rick and Morty season three video really soon.
Why don't we say Wednesday before I post my
Arrow 100th episode video so I'll explain
all that Rick and Morty stuff tomorrow that's
a completely separate show if you watch it
yet, everybody else in the comments that does
watch it will let you know exactly why it's
so awesome this giant DC four way crossover
is a logistical nightmare, but it gives me
so much hope for what they're going to try
next year because they always try to top each
other they try to do with the villains that
they bring on of the shows they also try to
do with the way they tell stories.
So when this is all over we can theorize about
how they can top this.
I have a couple pretty easy ideas and they
include Mongul and warworld to get hype let
me know what you guys most excited about.
I mean of is is a can be doing so much crazy
team up stuff in this is all based on the
invasion comic book storyline will be pointing
out all those comic book Easter eggs when
I post those Easter egg videos but see you
guys tonight is gonna be awesome what you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for my game of thrones season 7 teaser trailer.
Finally got some official footage and you
can click here for my flash playlist.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!